right now Luka 73 points what was your
mindset coming into tonight's game uh
get a win man uh we've been struggling
lately uh mindset was get a win uh and
we play great uh I we struggle a little
bit on defense but we play great offense
was there a point in tonight's game
where you knew this was a special one
for you no I was just going you know uh
whatever the defense give me in the
second half they double me all the time
so I Tred to make some plays uh sometime
I would just break the double so just
seeing the game yeah how big was that
when it got more physical and they were
double teaming you that Dante XM came up
big Josh Green as well it was great it
was a trust you know I always trust my
teammates you know uh make the right
play is always big time for us and next
man up you know they they were great
today well next man up that was
definitely you tonight you even had
Hawks fans cheering in this Arena did
you notice yeah I did I I heard some MVP
too so yeah it's beautiful well the most
points scored this year I franchise
record for the Mavs and a record for
this Arena where does this one rank for
you I mean probably on the top one of
the top you know uh but yeah I'm glad we
got a win and now you can catch a breath
thank you Luka thank
you